let's solve another second-order linear
homogeneous differential equation and
this one well I won't give you the
details before I actually write it down
so the differential equation is four
times the second derivative of Y with
respect to X minus eight times the first
derivative plus three times the function
times y is equal to zero and we have our
initial conditions Y of zero is equal to
two and we have Y prime of zero is equal
to one-half now I could go into the
whole thing you know Y is equal to e to
the rx is the solution substitute it in
then factor out e to the rx and have the
characteristic equation and and if you
if you want to see all of that over
again you might want to watch the
previous video just to see where that
characteristic equation comes from but
in this video I'm just showing you I'm
just going to show you literally how how
quickly you can do these type of
problems mechanically so if this is our
original differential equation the
characteristic equation is going to be
and I'll do this in a different color
for R squared minus 8 R plus 3 R is
equal to 0 and watch the previous video
if you don't know where this
characteristic equation comes from but
if you want to do these problems really
quick you just substitute the second
derivatives with an R squared the first
derivatives with an R and then the
function with with oh sorry no no this
this must be a constant so and then and
then the coefficient on the original
function is just the constant right I
think you see what I did right second
derivative R squared first derivative R
no derivative you could say that's R to
the 0 or just 1 but this is our
characteristic equation and now we can
just figure out its roots this is not a
trivial one for me to factor so if it's
not trivial you can use the quadratic
equation so we could say the solution of
this is R is equal to negative B well
negative B be
B is negative 8 so it's positive 8 8
plus or minus the square root of b
squared so that's 64 minus 4 times a
which is 4 times C which is 3 all of
that over 2a 2 times 4 is 8 that equals
8 plus or minus square root of 64 -
what's 16 what's 16 times 3 times minus
48 all of that over 8 what's 64 minus 48
let's see 12 it's 16 right right 10 plus
48 is 58 then another so it's 16 so we
have R is equal to 8 plus or minus the
square root of 16 over 8 is equal to 8
plus or minus 4 over 8 that equals 1
plus or minus 1/2 so the two solutions
of this characteristic equation and
ignore that let me scratch that out in
black so that you know that that's not
like a 30 or something the two solutions
of this characteristic equation are R is
equal to well 1 plus 1/2 is equal to
three-halves and r is equal to 1 minus
1/2 is equal to 1/2 so we know our two
R's
and we know that from previous
experience in the last video that you
know y is equal to c times e to the RX
is a solution so the general solution of
this differential equation is y is equal
to c1 times e let's use our first our e
to the 3 halves X plus c2 times e to the
1/2 X this differential equations
problem was literally just a problem in
using the quadratic equation and once
you figure out the RS you have your
general solution and now we just have to
use our initial conditions so to know
the initial conditions we needed a y of
X and we need
a y prime of X so let's just do that
right now so what's Y prime Y prime of
our general solution is equal to
three-halves times c1 e to the three
halves X plus derivative the inside one
half times c2 e to the one-half X and
now let's use our actual initial
conditions I don't want to lose them let
me write them down here so I can scroll
down so we know that Y of 0 is equal to
2 and Y prime of 0 is equal to 1/2 those
are our initial conditions so let's use
that information so Y of 0 so Y of 0
what what happens when you substitute X
is equal to 0 here you get c1 times e to
the 0 essentially so that's just 1 plus
c2 well that's just e to the 0 again
because X is 0 is equal to so this is
when X is equal to 0 what is y y is
equal to 2 y of 0 is equal to 2 and then
let's use the second equation so when y
when we substitute X is equal to 0 in
the derivative so when x is 0 we get
three-halves
c1 this goes to 1 again plus 1/2 1/2 C 2
this is 1 again e to the 1/2 times 0 is
e to the 0 which is 1 is equal to so
when x is 0 for the derivative Y is
equal to 1/2 are those derivative is 1/2
at that point or the slope is 1/2 at
that point and now we have two equations
in two unknowns and we could do a couple
we could solve it a ton of ways I think
you know how to solve them let's
multiply the top equation I don't let's
multiply it by three halves and what do
we get we get I'll do it in a different
color we get three-halves c1
three-halves c1 plus three-halves c2
is equal to what's three-halves times
two it's equal to three and now let's
subtract well I don't want to confuse
you so let's just subtract the bottom
from the top so this cancels out what's
one half minus three halves one half
minus one and a half well that's just
minus one right so minus c2 is equal to
what's one half minus three that's minus
two and a half or minus five halves
minus five halves and so we get c2 is
equal to five halves and we can
substitute back in this top equation c1
plus five halves is equal to 2 or c1 is
equal to 2 which is the same thing as
four halves minus five halves which is
equal to minus one half and now we can
just substitute c1 and c2 back into our
general solution and we have solved we
have found the particular solution of
this differential equation which is y is
equal to c1 c1 is minus 1/2 minus 1/2 e
to the three halves X three halves X
plus c2 c2 is 5 halves plus C 2 which is
5 halves e to the what was this up here
e to the one-half X and we are done and
it might seem really fancy we're solving
a differential equation our solution has
e in it and we're taking derivatives and
we're doing all sorts of things but
really the meat of this problem was
solving a quadratic which was our
characteristic equation and watch the
previous video if you just to see where
this you know why this characteristic
equation works but it's very easy to
come up with the characteristic equation
right I think you obviously see that Y
prime turns into R squared y prime turns
into R and then Y just turns into one
essentially so you solve a quadratic and
then after doing that you just have
take one derivative because after
solving the quadratic you immediately
have the general solution then you take
its derivative use your initial
conditions you have a system of linear
equations which is Algebra one and then
you solve them for the two constants C 1
and C 2 and you end up with your
particular solution and that's all there
is to it I will see you in the next
video